So the best answers for this question are that it does
depend on the number of keywords. If we have very few keywords,
well then, our lookup's fast enough. We're probably going to to have more
keywords than that, so we want our lookup to be faster. The
third possibility is not actually true. So, it doesn't depend on
how many URLs there are. And the reason for that is we're
doing a lookup based on the keywords. The number of times we
go through the loop and look up depends only on the number
of elements in index Which is the number of keywords, and
then the size of the URL list for each keyword doesn't impact
the time it takes to do a lookup. So it doesn't depend
on the number of URLs. Certainly, if we have more pages, we're
likely to have more keywords, so that would increase the size of
the index, but just the number of pages itself doesn't affect the
time for lookup. It does depend on how many lookups we want
to do. So if we only want to do one lookup and
that lookup takes a few seconds, well that's okay. It's probably not
worth spending a lot of time to make that one lookup faster, but
chances are we're going to want to do lots of lookups. Certainly if we
wanted to have a real search engine, we'd want to be able to
serve millions of lookups every day or in the case we will,
many billions of lookups everyday, every hour. So, if we want to do lots
of lookups, we want lookup to be faster. So, I
think we have good reasons to want to make our look up faster and
we're also going to learn some interesting computer
science concepts, by trying to do that.